first of all what have you learned about
life from Jane Goodall because she spoke
highly of your book and you list as one
of the mentors but what what kind of
wisdom about animals do you draw from
her
the wisdom from Jane is so diverse it's
I mean she first of all she's someone
that you know the work that she did at
the time she did it was so incredible
because I mean she she was out there at
a very young age doing that field work
she was naming her subjects which
everyone said you shouldn't do she broke
every rule she broke every rule she was
assigning and everyone said you know
you're anthropomorphizing these animals
by saying that they're doing this and
that and she she was like no they're
they're they're interacting they're
showing love they're showing compassion
they're showing hate they're showing
fear and and she broke straight through
all of those things
um and and it paid off in dividends for
her do you see the animals as having all
those human-like emotions of Anger of
compassion of longing of loneliness from
what you've seen especially with mammals
yeah but with different species out
there do they have all that it depends
on the animal you know if you're talking
you know on the scale of a cockroach to
an elephant you know it's like a lot of
these things and I wonder about this
stuff all the time you know I'll I'll
have a praying mantis on my hand and
just go what is going through your mind
you know yeah or you'll see it you'll
see a spider make a complex decision and
go I'm going to make my web there yeah
you know and you go how how are you how
are you doing this how are you because
he he made a calculation there you know
it's smart I was in the jungle not that
long ago and I'm I was walking and all
of a sudden this Dove comes flying
through the jungle right up to my face
lands on a branch like right here right
next to me I look at the dove Dove looks
at me and she's like hey and she's
clearly like panting and I'm like I'm
like why why are you why are you so
close to this is weird and she's like I
know
and then and then an ornate hawk eagle
flies up 10 feet away looks at both of
us and just like scowls and like sticks
up its head feathers and then just like
flies off and the dove is like sweet
thanks and then fluff flew in the other
direction it was like dude you just used
me to save your life yeah the dove knew
see well this is what
because there's diff you know there's
Mike Tyson and there's Albert Einstein
yeah and I sometimes I wonder when I
look at different creatures even insects
like is this Mike Tyson or is this
Einstein yeah like because one or other
kinds of personal like is this a New
Yorker or is this a midwesterner or is
this like uh San Francisco Barista of
the insects like there's all kinds of
personalities you never know so you
can't like project
like if you run into a bear and it's
very angry it could be just the
New Yorker yeah sure sure as opposed to
what he's saying about New Yorkers man
exactly Point well made